buongiorno vi spiego questa roba in
breve
dobbiamo andare a lucca non siamo a
milano quindi da milano dobbiamo dare
lucca quindi in lorenzo mi ha detto
svegliati alle sei e mezza del mattino
perché passo alle 7 un quarto così c'hai
i poco più di mezz'ora per prepararti
che anche poco io mi sono svegliato
circa 60 secondi fa quindi veramente mi
sono svegliato mi sono messo staffetta
che ho registrato e don hall e questo
perché quindi io meno quattro minuti
meno 5 adesso per fare tutto luca
arriviamo lei niente rai abbiamo perso
le chiavi della macchina quindi aveva
iniziato a smontare tutto quanto per
cercare di far partire quei cavi se c'è
su questo poi alla fine siamo riusciti a
mente a posti che invece di partire la
macchina predite una canzone di roma si
trova bene
praga dormire nel parma è la cosa più
infernale della vita anche perché
continua a sbattere la testa
così contro le strino perché non
riescono appoggiarmi
dormire in auto col cuore che andiamo a
lucca cosa succede
piove sempre fortunatamente quest'anno
c'è per te
si è come sempre assoluzione di prendere
tutte le occasioni mi ha ripreso anche
mentre dormivo vero lusso la facciamo
gara che si riprende il mio è un
cosplayer bellissimo e no volevo dirti
manica siamo degli sprovveduti come
sempre con its grassa e come si coniuga
con il vero politica sale non hai fatto
la scuola dimmi dimmi va verso il super
bordello a sé e non ti riconosce nessuno
a te rigore su tutti che mi riconoscono
come facciamo andare in giro c'è una
spesa che facciamo possiamo andare in
giro così normalmente perché sono amici
dicono sei anche stupido quindi anche
più facile riconoscerli non ho preso
delle maschere su amazon maschera che la
seconda maschera ragazzi ho utilizzato
la carta flash e ricaricabile che ha la
mia foto sullo sacer e ti rendi conto
che una carta a questa una carta a
questo punto dispongono che è
personalizzabile magari sceglietene un
altro
vi ringrazio che me la tengo ma lei
pagate the trattato guarda in giappone
ho pagato tutto io quindi aggiungiamo
pure due master che sia anzi a proposito
fammi controllare online quanto abbiamo
speso dal giappone acqua ecco infatti
non c'è più niente sulla carta al verde
poi compreso tutto io appena tempo la
ricarico e a proposito tua lavori
forzati come sei messo per ripagarmi
tutte le robe facciamo vedere i ragazzi
i lavori forzati che stai facendo per
ripagarmi tutto visto che non sono
ancora finite la giornata di editing
come al solito nel mentre quello lì
ministro fino al vetro bravo bravo
strofina bene che lì c'è una macchietta
bravo altri due anni così e te la cavi
mi ha ripagato tutto bravissimo
schiavizzate i vostri amici saranno dei
remi mito definito i vetri tutta la casa
quando si dice
campa cavallo c'è il corno piegato ecco
sei pronto
e però è spaccato questo acquisto
veramente bravo
corona di spine davvero
per noi tu sei date
ma la stai anche l'omaggio
quella di chiusura
in quella di dai da ragazzo devono
andare bailo youtuber dicevano vedrai un
sacco di fiere dicevano smentite ha
detto niente io vedo solo stronzo il
becco anche la parte più vero
travestimento per sotto
la donna scambiato a trovarci
potete fare qualche parte quanta poca
gente intorno e che sono timido
cosa una puntata di black mirror la
gente mi libro e basta non so ma mi
spiegate
mai spiega mentre mentre la sta facendo
ragazzi praticamente mi stanno
appiccicando imposti sulla testa io devo
capire ancora perché dove deve
indovinare il supereroe che ci ho
scritto in testa noi idea di chi sia
adesso
loro mi fanno una foto nel caso non ve
ne foste accorti c'è lusso che mi
riprende e poi ci sono persone che mi
fanno le foto e la mandano in direct ai
ragazzi di intesa sanpaolo giovani che
mi danno l'indizio per indovinare il
superiore con in testa
io vedo che non regolate sarete a valle
con in testa allora mi chiamo lorenzo
tutti due anni non bevo ma come potete
vedere ben problemi ben più gravi
allora il suo vero nome è wei min sono
winphone visto che è pazzo di step è in
grado di rigenerarsi come un altro eroe
della union un ottimo no quale dragon
ball una volta combattuto contro un
esercito di presidenti degli stati uniti
morti il lavoratore
per uscire se fate grave
vorrei subito ryan reynolds e non era la
domanda laurentiis investito proprio
come quelli di venerdì 13 dalle 4
periodo come fatica ma stiamo soft c'è
proprio il cosplay di colori scappato ma
io devo fare gente non lo sa bene da
tergo occhio di scappare e scappa esatto
casa.it è che sia stato dirti che
infatti gli acquisti utenti di tablet il
footer già mi devi tutto per il giappone
ci manca solo che è dovuta da mascara
che vuoi tu no niente scuse scherzava no
scherzavo o dai metti mi piace a tutti i
video però non sono iscritto al canale
neanche lui era iscritto prima e di come
è finito iscrivi scriventi un unicorno
in chiesa potrei dire di aver fatto dei
meeting in una chiesa ma non per fare un
meet and greet in una chiesa sconsacrata
meet greet da dio
sua eminenza possiamo andare
in arrivo chiamati a fare le foto alla
gente che mi fa le foto presa prima io
l'ho preso preso la apple e vi
fantastico uncem era meraviglioso se non
concerto in silenzio i mentecatti fatti
bene noi due noi due avevamo già fatto
una foto
avevamo già fatto una foto e io vorrei
far notare che foto che pochi cani che
gambe legandola al è un cancro e gandhi
non pagai ogni tanto disegno ed escono
delle cose veramente
scene però ogni tanto disegna notte i
ragazzi qua però fuori queste cose e
scherza c'è chiede se sapergli adesso
lei veggente e quindi ragazzi questa è
stata in sintesi la mia esperienza a
lucca comics
senza considerare che ho visto più
tramite il montaggio di questo video che
a lucca stesso perché ovviamente tramite
il montaggio dei video vedevo che mi
riprendevano e quindi vedeva un pò luca
dentro la maschera da unicorno non
vedevo assolutamente una ciofeca il
fatto è che c'è veramente già hanno
messo gli occhi c'è più vedevo
attraverso le narici del cavallo quindi
dell'unicorno quindi della ricevano qua
minuscole gli occhi dei posti non vedevo
niente però è stata una bella esperienza
nonostante questo perché ho fatto con
raduno in una chiesa lo fa il parroco lo
fa anche fa vigenti è una bella cosa
però che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi come ha
commentato mi piace anche a vari social
momento da una descrizione attraverso
siete e noi ci vediamo costruito ragazzi
[Musica]